- There was a release of
another, I'm going to say
shocking document.
NARRATOR: As extraordinary
as the notion of Forestalls
assassination may seem,
ancient astronaut theorists
propose that one of the
Majestic 12 documents
points to the assassination
of an even higher level
government official.
WOMAN: The story is that was
supposed to have been destroyed
and somebody put
it in a fire place,
and that another
person pulled it out.
MAN: So what does it say?
Top secret MJ12
Central Intelligence
Agency from director of Central
Intelligence Agency MJ1.
Who was that that?
That was Allen Dulles,
68 of 63 under Kennedy.
OK.
You must know Lancer
has made some inquiries
regarding our activities.
And Lancer during the
Kennedy administration
was the Secret Service
name for the president.
This is the head of the CIA--
MJ1.
Going against the president's
wishes of finding out more.
WOMAN: Which we cannot allow.
Please submit your views
no later than October.
If that was in 63, he was dead
one month later in Dallas.
ROBERT M. WOOD: The interest
of the scorched memo
is that if JFK keeps
doing what he's doing,
that he maybe is a problem.
It identifies a number of
actions that could be taken.
One of which, the
last one, implies
that if Washington does not
respond to what they want done,
it should be wet.
And that's the language
that the soviet
started to use
for assassination,
because wet is
associated with blood.
NARRATOR: If the Majestic 12
documents are indeed authentic,
are they proof that not only
were members of the United
States government
aware of and in contact
with extraterrestrial beings,
but also that they would
go to any length to
keep this information
hidden from the public.
Former Washington, DC
attorney Douglas Caddy
was a close friend of E. Howard
Hunt, who he represented when
Hunt was found to be at the
center of the Watergate scandal
in 1972.
Hunt was an officer
in the CIA when
John F. Kennedy was president.
Caddy claims that
he asked Howard Hunt
about the assassination
one night,
and received a shocking answer.
DOUGLAS CADDY: The last time
I saw Howard Hunt was in 1975.
He called me and said
he'd like to have dinner.
So dinner was finished-- we
went out to the sidewalk.
And I thought, well this may be
the last time I'll see Howard.
He's going away, and I'm
moving from Washington.
And so out of my own curiosity
I said to Howard, why
was John Kennedy assassinated?
RECORDING: Something has
happened in the motorcade.
Stand by please.
DOUGLAS CADDY: And
he said, John Kennedy
was assassinated because he was
about to give our most vital
secret to the Soviet Union.
And I said our
most vital secret?
I said, what could that be?
He leaned forward and
looked me in the eyes
and he said the alien presence.
He shook my hand
and walked away.
NARRATOR: If the stories about
the Majestic 12 are true,
and those involved
with a top secret group
were ready to take
such drastic measures
to keep its existence hidden,
was it ever discontinued?
Do you think that MJ12 is
still in existence today?
Well what I've been
told is that they
have changed the
letters and the numbers
probably more than once.
So it's the same idea.
It's the same control.
Same files.
Same archives.
Same power.
If you look at what has
happened in the last 60 years,
it's really possible that
more decisions have been made
in a side of our
government because
of this subject, ET's and
technology than any of us
would ever know.